Good morning, John.
We're currently being visited by a friend
and his 6-year-old daughter and I asked her
what she would like me to make my video about
today, and she said, "tarantulas in the guacamole."
I'm gonna assume that she means "Let's talk
about big, stupid, irrational fears".
It's probably not what she meant, but it feels
like it might be a bit of a stretch to spend
the entire video talking about guacamole tarantulas.
So instead, I want to talk about what I think
is the most common irrational fear in America
today.
And that is the fear that 50% of Americans
who surround us are thoughtless, and terrible,
and foolish.
Now this fear is every bit as irrational as
thinking there might be tarantulas in the
guacamole, but we all seem to believe it.
And I think that this comes from our addiction,
our absolute addiction to outrage.
Now, I wanna be clear, I'm not talking about
anger at systems of oppression, or frustration
at disenfranchisement, or fear that we are
making intractable decisions that are going
to have dramatic and negative consequences
for future generations.
Those are all completely rational reasons
to be upset.
I'm talking about the continuous and unrelenting
cycles of manufactured outrage, really manufactured
fear that I, you know, used to be a part of
and I used to encourage.
I used to think that outrage was our most
powerful tool for positive change.
You had to get people angry, and you had to
get 'em up and moving and doing stuff.
But what I've seen in my 35 years is that
angry people, the stuff they do, is mostly
they talk to each other about how angry they
are, and they talk to each other about how
wrong other people are, and then every once
in a while they interact with those wrong
people and then they just are mean.
And everyone does this.
Fake statistics get created and passed around,
we burn down straw men and we get to feel
good about it, because we believe, we've convinced
ourselves that this hatred - and let's be
honest, it's hatred - is somehow, like, leading
to positive change.
But when manufactured outrage is the fuel
with which we fight, we enter into a kind
of outrage arms race where the winner of the
election is the one that can terrify its base
the most.
Now, as I've tried to put my own addiction
to outrage in check, I've become a lot more
sensitive to the people who are out there
pedalling in it, and those people, on both
sides, have started to make me feel like super
sick to my stomach, already.
So as we enter - far too early - into the
2016 presidential season, I have already started
to figure out ways to build up my armor against
the outrage cycle.
This doesn't just calm me down and, like,
make it possible for me to get up in the morning
without being, like, weighed down by all of
the tremendous fear, it also - and I truly
believe this - gives me a more accurate understanding
of the world and our country and our culture.
Because outrage blinds us, it is built on
and builds bias and stereotypes.
It makes people really bad at understanding
how society and other people actually function.
So my tools, the ones I'm building, my armor
against the outrage cycle, are awareness of
my own cognitive biases, a belief in the fundamental
goodness of other people, that they want good
things for themselves and for their families,
and compassion.
Those are the things I'm using, if you have
strategies for dealing with this, please let's
talk about that in the comments.
In the meantime, I just analyzed the whole
Nerdfighteria Census of 2015 over at Hankschannel
and the results were fascinating.
Nerdfighteria has gotten older by three years
in the last year, which is weird.
We've gone from 24% college graduates to 33%
college graduates!
People love Crash Course, which is exciting
and the vast majority of respondents have
suggested Crash Course to their friends or
people in their family.
And people really want us to do some kind
of news show, which after having talked about
the current state of "news media," for the
last few minutes, I'm feeling compelled to
do also.
But it's very hard and I don't know that we'll
be able to do it, but we're looking into it,
we'll try to do that thing.
So thanks I'm glad that you would be interested
in that.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.